for years archicad has let us down with
their libraries and objects
however today marks the first day of a
brand new chapter
what's going on guys my name is david
thomich and welcome back to the channel
if you're new here thank you so much for
joining me on this channel we talk about
technology
and architecture if that's something
that interests you make sure you smash
that subscribe button down below
and let's get on with today's video like
i mentioned for years archicad has
truly let us down with their objects
they are
very very poorly designed and they are
very basic
so when it comes time to actually
creating some beautiful renders
it is definitely let down in that side
of things today i want to teach you how
to step
up your rendering game in archicad 24 or
in twin motion whichever is your
software of preference
i'm going to teach you where to get
these objects where to download them
how to import them into archicad and
also how to import them into twin motion
on a more positive note twin motion has
become recently available
on archicad so that means we've been
able to step up our renders
just that little bit however the more
and more that you create with twin
motion
the quickly you realize you run out of
objects and that they don't have
everything you need so for example i was
personally looking
for some flowers to put into a render
and it was driving me nuts that i wasn't
able to have
good quality flowers in marinda
so i went out and absolutely trolled the
internet for days to try
find the best rendering package or
rendering items out there and i kept
hitting wall
after wall at the wall because there was
so many platforms out there that didn't
cater to archicad or they didn't cater
to twin motion after a little bit more
digging and a little bit more research i
came across
a website called cg access.com
now this video is in no way shape or
form sponsored whatsoever
i found this website and because i spent
so long looking for objects
i feel like there are many people out
there that have this same situation
so i wanted to share the information
with you if you want to go ahead and
jump to the part that you're looking for
i've time stamped everything down below
so you can quickly jump to the area you
need
to see so let's start with cg access how
to access it how to get the absolute
best price because it is in
no way shape or form affordable when you
dive
straight in however i actually stumbled
upon a very good discount
which i'm happy to share with all of you
guys how to get that
and again not sponsored you're going to
have to do a few steps yourself so
cg axis has a million one different
objects
and when i say a millionaire one i'm
probably over exaggerating but only a
little bit
without over exaggerating i believe
there's probably
ten to fifteen thousand objects on this
website alone
that are compatible with either archicad
24
or twin motion in some way shape or form
that opens up your library
to a whole array of new possibilities
and to go even further it also has
building materials streetscapes textures
absolutely everything so if you need all
these extra bits and pieces it has all
that too but today i'm
really only focusing on the objects
themselves so if you were to stumble
onto cg access today and go to their
plans
or even just scroll through their
website you realize that every object is
12
15 20 us dollars it isn't cheap and it
definitely isn't affordable
to go through and download and pay for
each of these objects individually if
you go to their plans you can see that
you can get a one-year subscription
for 399 us dollars
for unlimited downloads 399
is a lot of money to spend on objects
that you may or may not use like i said
before fortunately i actually discovered
a way to get this
significantly cheaper so if you go to
the free collection
in the top hand bar type in your email
address they'll send you a link to
download
a bunch of free objects this is
personally what i did first
to download it and test out if these
objects would work in archicad and how
they would work
before i committed to buying anything
however when they actually did send me
that link
and i started downloading it in the link
they discounted that yearly rate from
349 i believe it is to 59 u.s
which is equivalent to 85 australian
dollars
at the current conversion rate so 85
australian dollars
for a one year subscription of unlimited
downloads
isn't a bad deal personally i was
looking at downloading about four or
five different objects
from this website that were about 12
each anyway
so to be able to spend a little bit more
to be able to download
absolutely everything made it definitely
worth my while
now it doesn't really matter what kind
of objects you're looking for if it's
anything from christmas decorations to
portable audio
or medical supplies to film studios it
can be
absolutely anything it doesn't have to
be your standard
kitchen tables dining chairs bedrooms
having said that they have
some amazing options there too again i
know this is sounding
very sponsored but absolutely not
sponsored whatsoever i'm just genuinely
excited
that we're going to have a huge array of
objects at our fingertips
now to use whatever way we want now cg
access
doesn't come without its flaws
unfortunately there are a few
first of all it isn't directly designed
to work with archicad and twin motion
you have to do a little bit of working
around
having said that it's very simple to
work around to be able to download some
of these files you're going to need a
pretty solid internet connection
some of them are a couple megabytes
others are a couple
gigabytes so if you're going to download
everything off
their servers you would be using
hundreds and hundreds of gigabytes to
download it all
and every single object that you
download be it 100 megabytes 200
megabytes
takes a little bit of time and then
takes a pretty big toll on your computer
what i personally found was i try to
incorporate some flowers into a design
which required a lot of flowers
this absolutely crushed my computer
the twin motion software crashed so many
times
and almost got to the point where the
file was no longer recoverable
so there is definitely limitations to
using
too many of these excessively large
highly highly detailed objects
okay so if you wanted to use these
objects in
archicad 24 directly how would you go
about it
well if you downloaded one of these
objects today and try to drag and drop
it directly into archicad
you'd find nothing happened most of the
files that come
from cg axis are either a cinema 4d file
a v-ray file an obj file or fbx file
none of these files are compatible with
archicad without some sort of add-in
so if you quickly google archicad 24
cinema 4d
add-on you can download the plug-in
to be able to add any cinema 4d objects
into archicad 24 directly
i'll leave a link down below if you want
to download that add-on
what i personally found though is when
you try to import a c4d
direct file into archicad it really
messes with things it just
creates it as air and fine lines so
all your materiality gets lost and it
becomes a really big burden
the best way i found to import it into
archicad
directly is to import the v-ray cinema
4d
version of this object so all you have
to do is literally
drag that cinema 4d object directly
in to archicad 24 let it load
go through the dialog boxes and you will
have your object
unfortunately one of the drawdowns here
is the simple fact that it imports it
into archicad 24
as a full white textured object that you
cannot change
individual areas of the material this is
where twin motion really steps it up and
i personally believe that importing them
into twin motion
first and completely leaving them off
archicad if you
are able to do so is the best way to do
it
so if you have twin motion 2020.2 open
this is the latest version available if
you aren't on that version feel free to
update at your own leisure
you are able to directly import these
objects by going
to the import option importing the
object
from your library and then directly
loading it in
i've attempted all four of these options
that come with all of these
objects the c4d the v-ray the obj and
the fbx by far the fbx
files are flawless when you import the
fbx files it imports them as a folder
with individual categories every single
different color
so for the bed that we're importing here
for example every different section of
that bed
is a different object in archicad that
can be turned off turned on
or re-materialized so if you don't like
the colors that come from cg
axis objects you can change that in twin
motion you can also scale
individual parts of this turn them on
turn them off
do as you wish and then to make things
so much
easier you can add them to your user
library so if you want to go and add
those
later down the track or in another
project they're already saved to your
user library
the biggest downfall though with cg
access
is the fact that every object is named
on their website
however none of the objects come named
when you download them
they just become cg access model blah
blah blah blah blah
it's really really difficult when you
download 10 or 20 of these objects
and you're trying to remember which one
is which so you're going to have to go
through
open them up rename them probably delete
all the extra files you don't need so it
doesn't take up excessive space on your
computer
and then import them and create a
template that is worthwhile for what you
need
anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed the video make sure you smash
that like button down below
so the youtube algorithm pumps it out to
more people if you want to see more of
these videos make sure you smash that
subscribe button down below and as
always
i'll see you next monday